vamos directo a Quito porque Ecuador va
a las urnas para tres votaciones el
próximo domingo unos comicios que ya
comenzaron este jueves con la
participación de cerca de 5000 presos
ellos votaron para cargos de elecciones
seccionales y también para elegir a los
siete miembros del Consejo de
participación ciudadana y control social
que es una institución creada con la
Carta Magna de 2008 para velar por la
voz de los ciudadanos en las decisiones
políticas además votarán un referendo
promovido por Guillermo lasso conectamos
con nuestro corresponsal en Quito
Gustavo Ortega Gustavo buenas noches
para usted y cuéntenos cómo fue la
votación hoy en las cárceles
Sí muy buena noche para ti María con
toda normalidad transcurrió el día de
hoy el voto de los privados de libertad
fueron más de cinco mil privados
libertad tal y como tú lo has dicho que
estaban habilitados para ejercer el
derecho al voto pero se realizó con un
amplio operativo de seguridad y
incrementando la presencia de la fuerza
militar y los policías que custodian los
paquetes electorales todo esto a
propósito de los alzamientos en las
cárceles que han ocurrido en los últimos
meses continuamente en este país por el
cual se realizó el proceso electoral se
espera también que el día de hoy también
cierran las campañas electorales
comience el silencio electoral la ley
seca también comienza el día de mañana y
se espera también que continúe el
proceso de votación de las elecciones
seccionales con el voto en casa un voto
que se realiza para específicamente las
personas con 75% de discapacidad mayores
de 50 años maraca y cuéntanos En qué
consisten las ocho reformas que propone
el gobierno en el referendo y que se
espera que suceda
bueno el gobierno ha presentado ocho
preguntas para una reforma
constitucional ha pasado todo un proceso
luego de calificación por parte de la
corte constitucional Pero en qué
consiste son básicamente ocho preguntas
algunas relacionadas con temas de
seguridad como la extradición la
consulta para que el pueblo ecuatoriano
decida si está de acuerdo con la
extradición de Ecuatorianos inmersos en
delitos de narcotráfico tráfico de armas
trata de personas para su extradición
hay otras preguntas también que tiene
que ver en cuanto a la autonomía de la
fiscalía hay otras también relacionadas
con el número de asambleístas reducir el
número de asambleístas De igual forma
también lo que sería la base fundamental
de la Reforma constitucional si es
también la de reducir las capacidades de
Selección del Consejo de participación
ciudadana y control Social es un
organismo de control creado como tú bien
lo dijiste en el año 2008 para la
selección de autoridades este organismo
selecciona 77 autoridades altos cargos y
el nacional ha insistido que no ha sido
efectivo y De igual forma también ha
estado inmerso en debates para poder
seleccionar Qué pasará bueno se realizan
también estas elecciones en marco de una
investigación un escándalo de supuesta
estructura de corrupción que señala a el
cuñado al presidente de la república Y
esto ha hecho más competitivo podría ser
más competitivo el voto El Ejecutivo
nacional ha intentado separar la campaña
electoral del propio presidente el lazo
para distanciarse un poco de el
principal involucrado su cuñado Danilo
Carrera